hi guys and welcome to episode 5 of
let's play City skylines today I wanted
to work on the detail of the city more
so than actually expanding it I'll get
into the smaller details of it later on
but the overall gist of it is that I
finally picked up the more
beautification smolt always if you don't
know what it is it basically allows you
to place props which are usually used
within buildings or parks or zone of all
elements in the game it allows you to
actually place those things freely so
for example small swimming pools that
you would normally get with a park you
can now just plop the swimming pool
anywhere free from the grid which
actually helps with many things
basically allows you to use those little
things like hedges and fences but also
lights and benches and small playground
elements that you normally come with
houses or buildings or parks just pretty
much anywhere to decorate your city
which is why I wanted to use this
opportunity to get back at some of the
things which I really felt my city was
missing so far and one of them really
was playgrounds in general but also
elementary schools basically if you go
to the Netherlands there is about one
elementary school per one row house
there absolutely everywhere and I
figured I would just open a bit of space
here in there for some more smaller
parks playgrounds and some elementary
schools not to mention some other misc
stuff which I've sort of missed so far
especially when it comes to this course
the prop you the more beautification
small is actually very useful of being
able to just freely place fences to kind
of zone of areas in a very non grid-like
way and being able to just block down
the small playgrounds anywhere it's
actually very handy which one of the
reasons why I really wanted to return to
that thing also one of the things that I
wanted to get in though it isn't too
much of a more beautification thing is
that I wanted to get some more very
small shopping things inside the city
basically in every sort of block of
houses or every neighborhood in general
you would have at least one small
supermarket or a small shopping street
and that's something which I'm so
of lacking so far I will go with the
more modern approach to it and rather
than rather than having really large
shopping malls or shopping streets
everywhere
I do wanna keep the focus a little bit
smaller um which is also from an in-game
perspective since I just can't
realistically get completely realistic
shopping malls and shopping streets in
with that really look convincingly touch
so yeah that's something I wanted to get
into as well and just random decorations
here in there like this little
industrial district where I figured I
could just go crazy with the hatches
anyway that's actually quite fun so far
I find that just using separate bushes
is actually a lot better for making
hatches then using the actual hatch
assets because even though the actual
hatch assets are obviously much more
realistic these hatches you just have so
much more freedom and where you actually
place them and the hazard assets as
great as they are they don't actually
conform to the terrain so you can't
really use them on hillsides and using
these hatches to sort of decorate slopes
is something that I've sort of found in
real life quite often and I wanted to
give it a shot and I kind of liked it so
far might wanna get addicted to that and
do it a bit more obviously one of the
other things which I wanted to do always
get back to parks and actually make them
look like parks pretty important point
of feedback that I did receive was that
I should stop making all the parks
entirely ornamental which is which is
actually a good point and I tend to
actually get lost in making parks well
look nice in terms of foliage but
actually forgetting to leave grass open
just to have a ball a game of Frisbee or
play football or stuff like that so
that's on me that I'll get to in the
future but it's really not something
that I can address right now given the
fact that this episode is already
recorded quite a while ago right now
oh and something that I should probably
say which you've probably already
noticed by now is that this is the first
episode which was recorded after I
actually recorded the first five
episodes so this was recorded after I
actually got youtube comment feedback
and found out that I can lead want to
upload this to YouTube which is why from
now on I'm not just addressing the
feedback more often which I couldn't
really do and just accidentally before
but also I think the quality should be
at least a little bit better right now
that said I can't really make it too
great
since my computer just isn't too great
and doesn't like City skylines too much
I can't put the dynamic resolution much
higher than this and other than that I
haven't got any graphical options that
can make the game look better and then
it currently does and also mention the
fact that and yes this is my own fault
but it's not something that I'll just
stop doing I render my videos twice once
to actually make the time lapses and
then another time to kill it commentate
over it which yeah you might say is
redundant I might as well just
commentate over Sony Vegas time lapse
footage raw without having to render it
first but I just kind of like to work
this way more plus it actually allows
you to just get a small stack of videos
and then just commentate them in a more
a higher resolution that grammar makes
sense so yeah that's that's two of the
reasons why the videos won't be too high
res but I do think as much of a opponent
as I am of the entire 60fps tobacco I
don't think it's really too important
for a time lapse obviously there's a
huge huge important improvement over
having a time lapse in 60fps rather than
30fps since there is a lot of movement
in here that with it is very jagged when
I move around a lot in the game I have
no idea what causes that but it's
something I might want to look into and
if anybody has any idea why that happens
then feel free to shoot because I have
no idea what causes it like if the
cameras just still which oh well that
was one other thing as you probably
address so this was also when I finally
decided that I would just keep the
camera still like a same person and it
sort of results in an look in a much
more watchable time-lapse in the end so
that should also improve the
but yeah I the FPS seems fine and the
resolution seems fine to me as well on
just the still shots where I don't move
around but as soon as I start moving it
just blurs up a little bit but the
framerate also drops which I get that it
blurs up but the framerate is quite
weird but yeah needless to say that
should be an issue which shouldn't be
too much of an issue anymore
but still if anybody knows anything
about it it would be really appreciated
to tell something about how I might be
able to fix it because it is still quite
a nuisance anyway to actually talk about
the game for a second
I wanted to get a small shopping street
over here I know this was exactly where
I felt the in-game limitations just make
it too damn near impossible to actually
get something realistic going and I am
pretty sure I probably explained this a
simulator stage when I recorded some
commentaries for real-time footage in
the future I can't even tell the future
and passed upon anymore but I just can't
really get the very realistic Dutch look
of shopping streets right since they
have a very distinct style at least the
slightly older ones do where they really
have a row of one large building with
shops underneath it and it's almost like
a very small interconnected mini more
sort of thing and at the moment I just
don't really know of any way to make
them so the small collection of
commercial buildings have villages
supposed to Emily emulate them but
they're not 100% the real deal other
than that
I'm actually quite happy about the
elementary schools pretty much
everywhere in the middle of all these
little neighborhoods in hindsight I
could have said that I probably wanted
to make them stand out a little bit more
and not just remove one grid of houses
and replace it with an elementary school
but rather put them in their own little
zones and parks and things like that
because they usually are but you know in
hindsight that was kind of hard to do
since I added these things later on so
I'm quite I'm a little bit more happy
about having these elementary schools
here then
having just antlers rowhouses everywhere
to say the least really now this is also
where I finally got back to actually
placing parking lots down and removing
some of these flats because it was a
little bit too dense and actually
replacing it with parking lots to make
sure that that is all all right I
actually really love this parking lot
this parking lot brush it's it's
something that you can just freely place
everywhere but cars actually use it
which is actually really awesome and
makes for a very flexible tool to
actually make some parking lots as
really unimportant of a city element it
seems it's unimportant to me I also know
this was recorded before I knew that the
foliage ham tool actually had a brush
using which you can delete trees so you
don't have to individually to leave
trees this one this was like 20 minutes
of me deleting individual trees I didn't
have to torture myself that way but I I
know now that you can just use a brush
so learn how to tell me about that but
yeah it was actually quite funny to
watch that back over here I wanted to
have a small area sort of like an
industrial district I don't quite know
what you would call them or if there's
even a name for it but usually just
outside the city you have these
districts where you have the larger
supermarkets or other types of markets
whatever you would have in your country
you really earn an Ikea
of course because you can't not have an
Ikea so this is my designated IKEA zone
IKEA and more and McKenney and in very
enhancer I'm very happy with this area
one of my favourite areas so far but
I'll get into that a little bit as I
finish these roundabouts over here I
also wanted to have a very typical dutch
dyke over here in his sense that i
wanted to make sure that i would always
have a road going over the top of it and
if possible also a bicycle lane at the
bottom of the dyke and perhaps a road
here and there as well and maybe in the
future also have a very small little
town attached to the up to the dike just
to get a more rural feel into this
entire area because I do plan
on making that entire area over there a
farming zone rather than large city like
everything is at the moment yeah this is
pretty much where my IKEA was built and
not too this is really not too
interesting and I don't even know why
I'm such a big fan of looking at it or
even doing at it doing it but yeah I'm
actually very happy with this zone it
sort of got and very that very edge of
the city
look eventually with just a couple of
offices and large stores and
surprisingly it's even a bit of a
traffic chaos I expected that not too
many people were to go over here but you
know I'm obviously commentating this
while after this episode was recorded
and by now like the city just floods to
the IKEA which is a bit of an issue but
that's something to be tackled later on
which is not because in a sense having
traffic jams is realistic too that's one
way to brush that argument away I
suppose and on the other side I just
wanted to get some simple offices in and
one more which I actually wanted to use
the in-game more for since it really has
like perfect shape for it it's not too
large but it's also not too small to put
it that two-bit way and it's just
building that I kind of like most of
many of the template buildings that you
get I'll definitely remove the water
pumps eventually they're really just
there as a temporary fix until I
actually make a whatever filter area but
so far their village is there to be a
functional tool to not have to do the
water area yet because I'm not too big
of a fan of doing it so far now this
area will also function as a transition
really to the rural landscape that I
plan on making next episode actually not
just in terms of traffic since this is
going to be the main entranceway to the
rest of the area which is one of the
reasons why I have always wanted to
actually have a roundabout intersection
over here since it has such a high
capacity but it's also sort of that
transition from
the real cityscape within the city to
the rural landscape religious crossing
fields which I do have to add there are
a couple of things which I probably
should say beforehand before people
start worrying about them I'm not going
to actually add any canals or the very
Dutch typical ditches since I've tried
and see kind of looked around for ways
to do them and actually build them in a
realistic way and I can really get them
right and I figured in the end I wanted
to go with something that would look
right rather than going for the more
realistic option even if it just would
look very weird some of the ditches were
just floating or the textures didn't
match and I can't use actual water
because of water physics and this means
that I also am not really going to go
for the very typical cow grasslands that
you find in Holland on most places in
Holland since I just can't realistically
divide them and make them look
convincing with ditches so it's mostly
gonna be in crops things like that that
type of Agriculture which is much more
like Easter in Holland released in the
eastern Netherlands I should say before
anyone gets mad but it's it's sort of a
way to get around having to try and get
ditches in here I might eventually do it
if like new a new asset comes out to
make them but so far it hasn't really
works anyway that's it for this video so
thank you for watching and see you later